alors on s'est installé là pour vous
montrer la crise est bien voilà on sait
qu'il ya des travaux mais écoutez bien
les compagnons du devoir travail et
alors vous avez écrit seul fait une
chose qui est assez drôle
vous avez joué avec avec la
communication on va dire dans cette
communication vous avez fait des
pancartes où il ya c'est vraiment là
c'est très bien c'est pendant les
travaux la visite continue ses 100
résumé a complètement montre les
coulisses du chantier on a une
exposition qui explique ce que c'est que
le métier de charpentier de couvreur
également de tailleur de pierre on
raconte les matériaux avec une
matériauthèque toutes nos visites
commentées raconte l'histoire du château
à travers ces différents chantiers
depuis le 16e siècle jusqu'à aujourd'hui
alors ce qui serait bien maintenant on
va se retrouver dans quelques instants
au coeur de travaux d'accord nous y
allons allez on y va à toute chute
qu'est ce qui donne ici où on est à côté
d'une charpente sur laquelle des voliges
sont actuellement en train d'être posées
et sept chars fin car elle date de 1857
puisque cette tourelle elle a été
réalisée par les marquis de biencourt
d'accord alors combien de temps avant
pour décider de dire ça y est c'est un
gros chantier
alors c'est très long d'instruire un
dossier pour restaurer un château comme
azay-le-rideau puisqu'il faut environ
une dizaine d'années de réflexion de
recherche de mobilisation aussi des
moyens avant qu'il y ait un passage en
commission nationale des monuments
historiques pour que le chantier soit
validé quant à la phase opérationnelle
on est entré en chantier au mois de
janvier de cette année et le calendrier
prévisionnel permet de dire que le
chantier sera terminé aux environs de
novembre 2010 cette perte convient
d'abord de personnes travaillent commune
corps de métiers représentés alors il ya
entre 20 et 40 personnes qui travaillent
en permanence sur le chantier vous avez
compagnons du devoir dans des corps de
métier de couvreur charpentier tailleur
de pierre le restaurateur de pierre on a
aussi d archéo m des spécialistes du
métal pour la restauration des épis de
faîtage qui sont des élites faîtage
exceptionnelle du 16e siècle
alors je vais dire une chose pis elle
est là le doubs elle a le don de
l'enchaînement parce que nous allons
découvrir un personnage est une personne
qui travaille justement avec ses épis de
faîtage ça complètement et qu'il ya un
métier extrêmement rare mais très
précieux pour la connaissance du
patrimoine a alors nous sommes allés
ensemble on vous regarde le reportage
archéo mais archéo m qu'est ce que cela
veut dire
avec un nom pareil donc direction le
dictionnaire larqué ou mitry et une
discipline scientifique mettant en
oeuvre des méthodes physiques ou
chimiques pour les études d'archéologie
bon confirmation car que maîtrise et 7 a
pour objet véritablement d'une étude
minutieuse de la matière mais l'objectif
c'est surtout de donner des arguments
pour comprendre ce qu'était le monument
à son origine
les tables de plo et les épis de faîtage
de la toiture était polychrome cette
couverture impose donc une étude très
approfondie les indices laissés par les
deux restaurations précédente donne 2
nombreuses informations sur les
techniques la méthode en deux mots un
véritable travail de fourmi s'éteindront
être mise en place à champagne mortels
donc elles finiront par totalement
disparaître un moment donné leur
polychromie pour commencer puis leur
matériau pour finir donc une certaine
manière les photos les mesures les
dessins que nous que nous faisons est
une manière d'enregistrer un matériau
qui intelligemment et remis en place
azay-le-rideau est donc un joyau
d'architecturé qui doit rester dans sa
parure d'antan après ces nombreuses
mesures et notent les restaurateurs pour
ensuite intervenir alors christelle il
ya une chose quand même vous avez pensé
à tout pendant les travaux
parce que derrière nous et on va le voir
en in algeria nous avait fait un
belvédère beaucoup on puisse partager ce
moment un peu privilégié qu'on a avec
vous de voir l'intérieur des travaux et
la magnifique voûte de la charpente
oui le belvédère ont fait permet aux
visiteurs comme on peut le voir à
présent d'être immergé sous la charpente
et de voir les couvreurs et les
charpentiers travail et donc on a pensé
aux visiteurs parce que notre priorité
reste les visiteurs c'est un lieu aussi
azay-le-rideau qui est connue à
l'international et le fait qu'il y ait
ce chantier du siècle devait être un
moment partagé avec le plus grand nombre
merci pour cette visite christelle et
puis on va donner rendez vous aux
téléspectateurs bien pour les journées
du patrimoine
je pense que là il ya double visite à
faire la visite un peu des travaux est
de comprendre la restauration et puis la
visite bien entendu de l'intérieur du
château qui lui on le rappelle n'a pas
du tout bougé
voilà alors en effet nous avons
rencontré des personnes ici des
touristes qui étaient là nul disais
c'est pas très joli c'est un peu dommage
que ce château soit empaqueter mais il
faut bien faire les travaux
j'ai peur qu'on vous a donné envie
d'aller visiter ce château
d'azay-le-rideau et je vous souhaite
d'ores et déjà deux bonnes journées du
patrimoine